ciao ragazzi benvenuti in questo nuovo
video che parla delle cose che odiano di
più le ragazze lo sanno e ragazze odiamo
tante cose ma pure ste ma proprio queste
ci fanno veramente imbestialire e sono
sicura che vi ritroverete in tutte
queste scenette qui volevo far vedere
che cosa mi ha inviato dei fantastici e
due di prima se io adoro ma non è finita
qui
oltre ai tubi tringolo immediato anche
questa scatola e voglio vedere cosa c'è
dentro insieme a noi gli diamo no vabbè
è uno speaker wireless da attaccare ai
tubi pringles nagata allora dentro c'è
appunto lo speaker le pile e abbiamo
tutto questo punto contiamo allora è
molto semplice perché vedete prendete lo
speaker lo mettete sopra il tubo solleva
della pellicola che ha corso e unghie
non riesco ma ce la farò vediamo un pò
ceretta ad horas e vediamo se funziona
molto meglio i ragazzi io a tecnologia
non andiamo molto d'accordo ma alla fine
ci sono riuscita perché mancavano le
pile quindi bastava metterle ho messo le
vide anche questo è le quinte in questo
qui insieme
e se funziona siete pronti ok adesso ci
siamo
vediamo subito col bluetooth
[Musica]
adoro mettiamo un po di music vediamo
allora
quindi ragazzi se anche voi volete
questa fantastica casa bluetooth
wireless da applicare direttamente sul
vostro gioco pringle non dovete far
altro che acquistare tre tubi di
aderenti all'iniziativa e seguire le
istruzioni che vi metto qui sotto ne
linking defezione e adesso via con le
cose che odiano di più le ragazze ci
vediamo alla fine del video
[Musica]
no
marie eve rossetto feriti sì sì sì la
storia fatta da regina così da poterlo
lo sto dicendo adesso ancora un po sì
no
[Musica]
ma ciò non ci credevo di visto
l'andamento guardaline per me stesso
vestito coincidenza tratto io aver fatto
un'occasione veramente storia cinquanta
per centro pagato 300 più completo ma
come 328 l'ho pagato 10 euro al mercato
la scorsa settimana eccoci qui spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto io questa cosa
di odio tantissimo immagino anche voi
iscrivetevi passato una cosa crediate di
più di più di più di più di tutte e
ricordatevi di mettere in ghiaccio
subito sottolinea iscrivervi a ferale e
seguirmi su tutti gli altri social cioè
in sé gancio è facebook slacciate
musicali
[Musica]